so as many of you know years ago tarik and i
were actors at a theater called boom chicago
in amsterdam now while we were there we did
a million improv shows and played a million
improv games and we loved it so we
thought we'd play one for you guys
tonight and we invited some friends to
help us out with it please welcome our
buds from the hit broadway show freestyle
love supreme anthony teen touch venice alley
tyler taser rose arthur the geniuses
louis and tarek tarnish heart away davis
now after a long hiatus for the
pandemic their freestyle rap
improv show is finally back on broadway
at the booth theater isn't that exciting
that's right tarek has a second job on
broadway that's real he's a show-off
that is also real so we are going to play an
improv game called conducted song okay okay
so we're gonna sing a song for you right now
but we are going to make it up entirely 100
on the spot and you are going to tell
us what that song is going to be about
so please shout out a suggestion of any
everyday object like a blender or a hot dog or
margarita a oh [__] someone said margarita
machine but someone else said spatula
and i have to go with margarita machine because
i see that [__] in my kitchen every day right
the suggestion is margarita machine anthony
tarrick and i will be singing the song
margarita machine and kayla will conduct that
song while she beat boxes at the same time
these guys can only sing when i point
to them and when i point to them
they must sing and like any good song it will
rhyme okay okay okay a steam guess we present to
you the new hit song margarita machine all right
all right ready arthur and five six seven eight
come on amber i like to get drunk
dirty i like to get drunk clean
i like to get drunk with my margarita machine
margarita machine i have to say you truly are the
best that's right margarita you got me impressed
margarita drink it down margarita drinking
down you make me try to walk like a clown
margarita oh you are so very lovely margarita
don't you know you make me drunk and
ugly margarita i have four five
and i'm worse off than i thought
but i don't know what to do because i'm
drunk as a stone margarita drink it down
you better bring your margarita machine
because
rat break your margarita oh damn you got my rim
salted margarita i don't know how i'm gonna cuff
it singing margaritaville like i'm jimmy buffett
margarita who the [__] is him just give me some
can't do no wrong
mcdonald makes me frown margarita you
want the toast of the town margarita
thank you
thank you so much to priests please
give them a huge round of applause
and please go see their fantastic show
broadway at the movie my voice went out
you